hey guys it's Justine and today's video
is going to be kind of cool because I
want to get the chance to show you this
really fun feature that YouTube is
rolling out for the holidays it's called
YouTube shopping so a huge thank you to
YouTube for partnering with me on this
video now some of the products that I'm
going to show you here today are
actually gifts that I have bought people
in the past and they are like top gifts
that have had incredible reactions now
obviously it's interesting because as I
get older I feel like the things that I
get excited about are a lot of Home
Goods Smart Home Products things to make
my life a little bit easier for cooking
for cleaning for lighting so today I'm
going to share with you a few of the
things that I have absolutely loved
gifting in the past and things that I
basically feel like I can't live without
in my home currently so with YouTube
shopping it's a really great way for
audiences to share products that they're
already talking about and you guys can
actually shop them directly from the
video if you want to check out any of
the products that I've talked about in
today's video you can click the view
products label and you can shop them
directly from here so the first product
we're going to talk about today is this
Dyson humidifier now this not only is a
humidifier but it is also an air filter
and it will also filter out formaldehyde
I am such a huge fan of Dyson because
they have such a huge line of products
especially when it comes to their air
filters because they have some that will
not only provide heat but they will also
have cooling now I have one in my house
and we recently got one of these for my
parents and they absolutely love it I
have several different sizes of these
Dyson purifiers in various rooms in my
home I have one here in the studio and
the one that I have here is the
formaldehyde one this is using Dyson's
most advanced filtration system so it
combines a precise solid state
formaldehyde sensor with a unique filter
that continuously destroys formaldehyde
this filter removes gases and odors and
a HEPA filter captures 99.97 of
particles 0.3 microns in size it has
powerful air multiplier technology which
projects purified humidified air
throughout the room Maddie
oh my God
Maddie no she's busy
I also really like this because it can
be voice controlled and honestly if
there's anything in my home that I can
control with my voice and I don't have
to do anything else I am so here for it
now this next product is very high on my
list of basically just items I cannot
live without this is the Brava home oven
and this is an infrared oven now not
only does this connect to an app but you
have this incredible library of recipes
that you can basically make anything
that you can even think of inside of
this thing I honestly just use it a lot
of times every single morning to make
toast I make a lot of egg breakfast
sandwiches in this thing you can make
some really fantastic gourmet meals just
inside of this oven this is my favorite
feature of the Bravo oven is it has a
camera that's connected to it so right
now I'm watching my English muffins be
cooked like I can see them they can't
see me but I can see them
and my morning routine normally consists
of putting in my breakfast sandwich my
eggs I hit start running in a shower I
have my phone open so I'm actually
taking a shower watching my food cook
and I time it just so I can hop out of
the shower when my food is going to be
done
oh it's hot it's so hot I don't know I
don't know I'm not sure
another thing I like is if this wasn't
crispy enough I could do a little touch
up
but obviously this is very very crispy
and worth that
we good now again this is an Incredible
Gift it is a little bit on the more
expensive side but I promise you this is
the gift that keeps on giving we have
got one of these for a bunch of my
friends as gifts my family and pretty
much most of my friends at this point
they have bought one because of me and
my sister non-stop talking about it so
thank you Brava for being such an
incredible gift and also something that
has completely improved my life it's
just so much fun and I honestly cannot
say enough incredible things about it
now this next gift which is actually
something that I already have but I just
got a couple extras for myself this is
nanoleaf now I love nanoleaf I like them
a lot because these have thread
technology so you don't need some
separate kind of Hub to actually make
these work you kind of just hold them up
close to your phone they work with home
kit and the ones that I have here today
I've got the nanoleaf essentials so this
has 3D for light bulbs and this one I
actually got for my living room this is
a light strip so this is going to go
behind my TV I can't wait because you
can connect this to your phone you can
change it to a bunch of different colors
and it's pretty much another piece of
life-changing Tech I'm actually gonna
open the bulbs
nanoleaf also has a ton of other
lighting accessories
I got these ones specifically for my
office because I have a light that has
three light bulbs and I kind of want to
change the Hue because I just painted my
office pink so I wanted to change the
colors and light bulbs that I have in
there now or just basic LED lights and
why I think this is a great gift for
people is because you don't need to have
some special thing that connects to your
router and it's pretty easy to use okay
here it is one of the lights is already
installed so I have to put the other two
in it was super easy all I had to do was
scan the QR code I installed the light
and it automatically connected to my
home let's put the other two in
[Music]
foreign
there we go all three are now added so I
can choose my lights inside of my Apple
home app and I can also adjust these in
the nanoleaf app to make them any color
I want so I can go in and change the
colors of these lights I can go in and I
can make pink I can make it blue and I
can make it green I'm so excited about
this I buy new lights my new pink wall
spoiler alert for a future video but I
usually keep my lights kind of turned
this way just so it kind of gives me a
little light reflecting off but I'm
really excited about having this now in
here because I can basically change them
any color I want turn them off and on
from my app it's pretty exciting plus
it's gonna look so great in my living
room
these are so cool I'm so hyped
so one of the reasons that I was also
really excited about this is because I
don't really decorate for the holidays
but with this I can start changing the
colors of the lighting in my home very
very easily you can have a nice theme
while you're watching your favorite TV
show or you know your favorite YouTuber
on YouTube hi hi that's me it's okay if
I'm not your favorite
just maybe like top three maybe which
will put me there
now my last gift that I'm going to show
you is the ring stick up camera and
actually
well
you can't see it but it's right here
[Applause]
I'm a really big fan of these stick up
cameras mostly because of the size and
the battery life on this actually lasts
a pretty long time you can actually get
a solar panel connector so if you do
want to stick this outside there's a
solar panel that will be able to power
it there is also a wired AC connector
that you can get to connect to an outlet
but I mostly just use the battery
powered ones I always have a battery
that is charged on hand and I just pop
it in whenever I need it so I have this
connected to the Ring app so I'm going
to hit go live there we are we are live
I'd like to keep this here in the office
it's a nice view I can basically see
everything I'm gonna end that because
you're gonna actually be able to see me
shooting this video like this is me
setting up you know I'm scrolling
through look at that look at me work I
was itching myself
so this was this morning at 2 35 a.m
cleaning up getting set up all
set up and we're back to live but I want
to share this I just couldn't Click
Share I can share this with my neighbors
if there was a crime if this happened to
capture a crime I could share with rings
so this could be a video that's featured
by ring or I have some more options I
can email text or copy the video link
and here's my question this is going to
he'll actually be okay there it is there
we are we doing live so that's the ring
stick up camera huge fan and I'm sure
many of you guys have actually used
these before so if you have I'd love to
hear from you in the comments below what
do you think have you captured anything
cool okay we're gonna put you back now
back where you belong thank you guys so
much for watching this was such a fun
video and again if you want to check out
any of the products that I talked about
today now with YouTube shopping you'll
be able to shop them directly from this
video this is such a cool feature and
I'm so excited about it and of course
the holidays are right around the corner
so of course YouTube shopping can be one
of the great places that you can get all
of your holiday shopping done just by
watching YouTube videos pretty cool if
you guys haven't already please
subscribe to my YouTube channel I will
see you guys in my next video and in
comments below bye
[Music]